what I haven't been willing negotiate
and I will not negotiate is on the debt
sir President Obama has been insistent
that he wants a clean bill to increase
the debt ceiling or the amount of money
that the federal government can borrow
at any one time but here are three
reasons we need a dirty deal one with a
lot of constraints on how much spending
the government can do now and in the
future I don't think anybody would
consider my position unreasonable here
total national debt now is about 17
trillion dollars or the equivalent of
all economic activity in the United
States taking care of that debt paying
that debt and increasing that debt takes
money away from better uses by the
government I don't think anybody would
consider my position unreasonable here
the congressional budget office projects
that over the next 25 years spending on
the debt will double as a percentage of
GDP and that means it will crowd out
money that could be used for private
investment that would be much more
efficient and lead to economic growth I
don't think anybody would consider my
position unreasonable here tying any
increase in the debt ceiling to
immediate and long range cuts in
spending is the only way that will be
able to deal with the old age
entitlements like Medicare and Social
Security that are already unsustainable
and will definitely bankrupt the country
in the long run contra president obama
we can't afford a clean bill to increase
the debt limit in fact what we need is
the dirty is still possible and sooner
rather than later for reason TV I'm
Nicolas